the universe is ultimate reality which
is
some people refer to it as god some
people would refer to it as the one
monad
the universe has its own much more
powerful kind of cognition where it
literally apprehends everything at once
we get to sense and control the universe
through the body that's how we can have
a metaphysical nature and at once have a
physical nature a physical body the
reality is telesis which is a
combination
of energy and information
the information determines how energy is
distributed in the terminal manifold
that's why telesis has to factorize
itself into content and medium and this
is irreducible
you can't quantize reality any more than
that
okay it can't get any simpler what must
the structure of that medium be in order
for you to have the ability to bring
observer and
percept and recipient together in a
perception what must that medium be
and that's what the ctmu answers
everybody comes up with great ideas all
the time the object is to interpret them
in one unifying framework yeah so the
ctmu is designed to be that unifying
framework or foundational language
in which all of these other insights as
great as they are can be interpreted
together so that conflicts and paradoxes
don't arise among them is the one thing
that characterizes great art is the
number of different ways you can
interpret it that means that it's very
hard to maintain a stable correspondence
between
people the observers of a work of art
and the work of art itself okay its
meaning ends up being ambiguous because
when you add everybody's opinion of what
it means they tend to cancel out this is
what the mathematics is for you see it
restores that cancellation okay you've
got actually got a correspondence that
you can put your finger okay so although
i admit the value of the artistic
interpretation aspect because that's
what really engages us
bringing all those different engagements
together
that requires logic and mathematics
no defense or buts about it both sides
have their purpose
to come together
as it happens however the world the
current tendency is towards
centralization the centralization of
wealth and power and now we've got this
tiny little handful of no goods that are
basically trying to tell everybody else
what to do as they accumulate all the
wealth and all the power for themselves
that
negates the entire purpose of the
universe it kills the point right so we
need to spread things around we need to
have more of what is called
individualism decentralization as you
put it uh instead of centralization are
they going to let
the telec recursion of the rest of
humanity come to fruition and give
humanity what it wants or are they
simply going to continue with their
ongoing agenda of accumulating more of
the wealth and power for themselves
you eventually choke off telegrams you
stop the intentionality of the positive
intentionality of other people from ever
coming to fruition
that's what they're doing
okay so if there's no means to stop them
all right then we've got a problem very
few of these people appear to want to
restore that balance they just want to
they appear to want to get richer and
richer and richer thusly making society
more asymmetrical and more unbalanced
that's a problem
these people are trying to shut down the
mass awakening that you want and that i
want before it even happens
hey everyone atlas here i'm introing the
interview we just did with chris langan
it was super powerful on many different
fronts one of my favorite interviews
we
interestingly spent the first
hour or so about
consciousness
the nature of reality
the one
infinity
and
played with
several of chris's
technicalities
and his
mathematical framework
we then
naturally progressed in the second hour
to talking about
meeting basic needs and actualizing our
fullest potential and
this rock
as we called it of separation this rock
of ego and this rock of many of the
matrix control systems that are in place
that are preventing the collective
awakening and decentralization and
universalization
and then at the very end it was
fascinating we explored how important it
is for these beautiful
artistic
syntheses of science and spirituality
these distillations of the nature of
reality that are made visual
for them to incorporate mathematics for
them to incorporate logic for them to
incorporate
a
coherent
systematization
language framework for there to be a
even more cohesive understanding of who
we truly are and why we're here and how
to awaken and what we awaken to i am so
pumped for you to enjoy this interview
i'm also pumped for you to
support chris if this resonates with you
he's independently bringing forth his
ctmu i would love for you to check out
more of his work and to support him if
this resonates
and enjoy everyone i'm pumped
this is it
this is us bringing forth the nature of
reality more and more
us awakening reality awakening to itself
life awakening to itself the one
awakening to itself through the dance of
a universe and sentience
now the way i understand if you want to
talk about uh just generalities more or
less
yeah so let's go ahead and dive in i'll
go ahead and intro the show
okay
hey everyone welcome to simulation i'm
your host atlas
super excited for this interview
with chris langen chris thanks for
coming on the show
well you're very welcome man it's my
pleasure
and i'm super excited it was last year
that i initially stumbled across your
work it was when i was seeking the
nature of reality answers
and i remember coming across ctmu and
being really excited about it and it led
me into so many interesting
uh understandings about
consciousness and about the universe
and about infinity and that was super
pumped for me
and
then i had messaged you interested in
interviewing you
but back then it would have been a lower
quality interview given
today one year later what i know this is
going to be really epic
with my realizations and my conviction
and so i'm so excited and actually it
was because kurt jaimongo who we also
had on the show
he had interviewed you and then i had
mentioned to him that i was so excited
to interview you and that he linked this
up with gina and then again now with you
and so
i'm
jacked i'm so excited
i'm glad to be here
heck yes
so
yes like we talked about i am interested
to chat with you about yes
um the nature of reality consciousness
infinity um and i feel like one of the
best places to start is just going
directly
at
the source of how the universe
comprehends itself
and would you say that that's obviously
cognition
it's a form of cognition although it's
not the same as human cognition the
universe has its own much more powerful
kind of cognition where it literally
apprehends everything at once but it
does so through the eyes of all of its
secondary television which of course are
includes human beings like us
so how does the universe comprehend
everything at once
well now if i were the universe i could
tell you that
unfortunately just like you i'm a
localized creature within the universe
so my
perception is usually limited unless i'm
getting some kind of help or i'm
occupying a higher form of consciousness
uh usually i can't see very far beyond
my own low count so
the reason our consciousness is that way
is so we can survive on this level of
existence
this is terminal reality so we have to
stay in touch with it that means we have
to we can shift our focus but our focus
always has to be in terminal reality at
least when we're actually coping with
threats dangers things that we want
things that we need to do we have to
stay attached to them and that's what
our consciousness is tailored to do
there are however higher forms of
consciousness that it is very hard for
us to conceive using just the form
inside our heads
um
but if you can deduce for example that
the universe has a kind of sentience and
that sentience is necessarily different
from our
level of consciousness in certain
respects then you may safely ascribe it
to the universe because it's a matter of
logical necessity
cool so where is the universe's
sentience if it's not localized
within the sentient creatures
it's distributed over everything in the
universe in the ctmu the points of the
universe are events which actually
contain states interacting states they
interact in events and these are the
points of the manifold
the sentience of the universe is
distributed over all of those points so
that it misses nothing
in other words people people wonder what
does you know what is this higher
sentience what is the mind of god uh
what does it perceive it perceives
everything through every point
okay so
the sentence is distributed
across a manifold
yes
you know what a manifold is right many
fold
that's one way of looking at it it's
also a certain kind of space
and you can describe properties to it
for instance uh it's locally euclidean
in most cases which means that we have
something approximate in euclidean
geometry
in our separate frames of reference
and
they're
the conspensive manifold of the ctmu
differs from ordinary manifolds in
certain respects
one of those respects is of course point
structure i've just described points in
a different way than most mathematicians
would describe the points in an ordinary
manifold
in an ordinary real manifold for example
which is a
manifold parameterized by real numbers
points are zero dimensional cuts in the
manifold
the cut is something of course that has
to be bridged from one
from one point to another or one section
of the space to another so they can
actually separate
the
space that's what a cut does but of
course then if you separate the space
the space is not connected and it falls
into pieces
also of course a cut is of zero
dimension within the space it's actually
it has no size it doesn't take any space
up in the manifold
therefore it has extent zero in the
manifold now if you add up all of those
points because we all know a manifold
consists of its points it could be
decomposed to its points if we take the
extent of all of those points and add
them up again we get zero
so that's uh that leads to a paradoxical
construct
it's uh oxymoronic to talk about a real
manifold whose points are cuts so we
must define redefine the manifold in
such a way that it makes sense
and that's what a con expansive manifold
is designed to do
okay so we have the universe
comprehending itself in a distributed
way
correct okay and then
this
feels like it plays
really well into the conversation of the
synthesis of science and spirituality
because
on a spiritual level there's so many
mystical wisdoms around consciousness
and around
awareness and then on a scientific level
there's so much
excitement around physics and around
quantum mechanics and biology and
chemistry these very materialistic
building blocks
and so the two are ultimately one
and let's see if this is aligned with
what you were saying a moment ago which
is that
consciousness or perception depends upon
the material or the physical
well
consciousness is dual
when i say duel what i mean is
if somebody into asian philosophy would
say non-dual those would mean the same
things but actually we used dualism for
that concept
for for the concept of two things being
separated and duality for the idea that
two things coincide in one particular
point now consciousness must have
this duality
in other words we have to have
a set of patterns which in the ctmuse
called syntax in terms of which we see
the world and then we actually have to
have
a body with which we are in contact that
is actually in the world so that serves
as a kind of sense or controller yes
we get to we get to sense and control
the universe through the body that's how
we can have a metaphysical nature and at
once have a physical nature a physical
body
beautiful we say that we say that every
physical point in the consequence of
manifold has a metaphysical neighborhood
that due to certain mathematical
considerations uh in effect in the
consensus manifold has to be both
interior and exterior to every point
but we use certain distinctions like
those between semi languages in the ctmu
in order to separate them so that we can
consider them separately
okay
nice
great so then this
uh not this twoness and this not twoness
are simultaneous so that both
the metaphysical and the physical nature
are both can be separate
and viewed that way but they can also be
viewed as the same as dependent on each
other
yes and a consequence of manifold you
know
basically things
states collapse out of events in which
they are actually combined
they are acquired together by something
called telom and then they collapse by
quantum wave function collapse so that
medium is separated from content the
state exists as content within a medium
and those two things are factored apart
and made
temporarily dualistic
so that you seem to be
set apart from the terminal domain
uh in ordinary terminal consciousness
you actually seem to be separate from
the world okay well here's me out there
is the world but uh on a deeper level of
structure in the consensus manifold you
actually cannot be separated from the
world
you're embedded in it in a very real way
and you can't extract yourself
yep
and you use the word sensor earlier and
i think that's a very important word so
out of
uh infinite potential
that
we are would you say that we are
infinite potential
yes of course
you know
a lot of people mean a lot of different
things by infinity and by potential so
you have to kind of define what those
are
you know and uh and the ctmu does that
if we get into all the technicalities
probably gonna start losing some people
but
um yeah infinity is all about
discernment it's all about
what you can discern as a specific
element in the set
you know how cantor defined a set right
in terms of two operations discernment
and aggregation
aggregation is basically creating the
intention from the extension of the set
whereas
discernment is the opposite direction
you use the aggregation to identify
the elements of the set rather than
anyway you've got to use both you've got
to both use the intention and set to
identify the extension and the extension
from the point of view of a point within
the set you've got to be able to
identify the intention
so that's the kind of duality that you
need to make consciousness work
in the terminal
cool so with this infinite potential
that we are
we then use the
the substrate or the technology or the
design of
energy
that manifests as universe
recursively
like cells
that then
enable us to have these sensors
is that how you also see it
well yes what happens is the universe is
quantized in terms of things called
syntactics that can actually accept
input from the universe and then return
output in the forms of state transitions
or behavior
so
on one side of that you've got
acceptance which in computation theory
you know what an acceptor is right it's
just a little
it's an automaton that accepts input
from the outside world and then
you know becomes throughput and it's
processed inside the syntax and then
it's used then it's classified actually
becomes a classifier and then
you get output that can actually be
returned to the world in the form of an
external state as opposed to the
internal state of the syntactor
now
customarily mathematicians define a
manifold in terms of points with no
internal structure we've got no
structure at all because they're cuts
in the ctmu points are defined in terms
of states that are syntactors that
actually have this input output capacity
and the input capacity is the sensing
capacity that's what makes it a sensor
and then the controller part is the way
we can actually control
what our bodies do
by using internal designs it's across
the world design
right intentionality yeah right
and that is that exists in in the
manifold in a semi language that is
actually located in the future
so that things flow out of that sunny
language
to the output language
from future to past whereas there's a
contravening uh semi-model that actually
flows in the opposite direction
cool [ __ ] sony model and an advanced
seminar
nice so there's
so there's both this
this inputting of
sensations that dance
in what we could say is an empty
cognizing mind
and then there's also this
intentionality or will
choice
that then we
are the painters
god is the painter
through these sensors that are these
human body vehicles
well to be very colorful about it yes
that's that's a metaphorical way of
expressing it
um dancing and painting
aren't the not necessarily the concepts
that i ordinarily use to explain it but
they certainly do fit so i can
actually empathize with you with your
expression do you feel like there's
benefit of uh
leveraging the like artistic way of
expression with um dancing and painting
as sort of an explanation of infinite
potential and using these universes to
do so
but also at the same time having this
very
logical and conceptual and idea based
the simultaneity of those two
well those are
both very closely connected and both
necessary sides of reality cool a
reality would be worth nothing to us if
we couldn't be creative and artistic
we're all creating our own destinies as
we move from past the future
and from future past
and uh this is something that is very
important to us there would be no point
to having a reality at all at all if we
couldn't do that so this idea that the
reality that the terminal manifold
space-time is just some kind of theater
in which
inert particles bounce into each other
and
certain phenomena happen under the
direction of physical law that that
that's
not a world that anybody would actually
want to live in we actually have to have
mentality we actually have to have
intentionality and the other things that
we know subjectively and so the manifold
of reality must be designed to
accommodate
which unfortunately the cartesian
manifold the space-time manifold most
manifolds is conceived by mathematicians
and physicists do not
that's why we define the manifold in a
different way in the ctmu so that we can
sense and control
and perform the creative functions that
we associate with actually living on
this planet as a human being
cool
so let's play with the painter analogy a
little bit more so
do you see
us as
god
i see us as there is in the ctmu
a god it's it's
basically synonymous with ultimate
reality or
neoplatonists might have called it the
one or the monad
um yes this is god and god actually that
that monad actually has the properties
that we used to describe to god
including sentience
so so uh
yes
cool
and we're all god in that sense but
there are differences between
us and god
okay
although we all share one ultimate
identity
we're all canonically identical in
god nevertheless we we are not god we
can't simply realize our thoughts just
like that
okay god can do that from his own
perspective instantaneously
we on the other hand have to sometimes
work very hard to make things happen
because we're all working with and
against each other
we've got to allow
for what everybody is doing to reality
in order to make our own particular
realities mesh and fit together
um
god doesn't have that problem he tries
to ease
our interactions for us he makes them
happen as smoothly as possible that's
another feature of this manifold that
i'm talking about actually has levels of
organization
that permit this to happen
so
go ahead
go ahead would you call god an unbounded
energy
i would not call god a mere energy and
physics energy is is defined as the
capacity to do work yes
okay but if you're going to talk about
and of course in energy energy and
physics is the ultimate reductive
substance of reality everything reduces
to energy that's correct equals mc
squared means the matter and energy of
the sin
so the universe that appears to consist
of matter actually consists of energy
embedded in some kind of space-time
media okay that's what physicists think
but when we talk about metaphysics and
we talk about god we have something
called information
that also plays into this and
information is a more complex entity
that requires linguistic structure to
exist
in other words language is the vehicle
of information you've got to have
attributes and you've got to have values
and you've got to have an attribution
operation which is mainly logical
but these things you got nothing
this is often overlooked by
mathematicians and physicists who who
more or less add the content of their
own minds to reality and think that it's
all out there in reality without
recognizing that they're really adding
it
to reality and they're really performing
certain functions that reality does not
perform
nice so
potentially rather than the phrase
reality is energy doing work you would
say reality is information doing work no
i would say that reality is telesis
which is a combination
of energy and information
nice absolutely
basically the information the
information determines how energy is
distributed in the terminal mount
the terminal in terminal domain
in space time so information determines
how the energy is distributed
that's correct the kind of information
we're talking about right now there are
many different kinds of information but
the kind that we're talking about which
is opposite to metaphysics is the kind
of that we need
so um to tell us or tolesis do you have
a preferred pronunciation i usually
pronounce it thomas
tell us
okay
and then now
let's play with the word telesis this is
very important so this comes from greek
telos
right
right and it comes in telos meaning
purpose
yeah there you go
and then meaning that there is a
an end there is a there is a reason for
this there's an explorative um process
that this is it means that there is an
ultimate monarch meta substance
that actually it contains its own ends
its own purposes and actualizes those
purposes
from potential which means that it must
factorize into potential and actuality
that's what it does by an operation
called
conspansion which contains another
operation called teleconversion yep
okay so from the infinite potentiality
there's an actualization of said
potential using teleconcursion
there you go
okay
and then
now telic recursion um plays
uh one of the simplest ways to see it
from what i see is a cell
so the procedure calls on itself the
cell hits a certain checkpoint in its
cell cycle and then it divides and
there's two cells
and so it's recursive in that sense
and then
don't agree
yeah i'm losing your entire cell analogy
here what
well for example within us humans there
is a
um
there's a tetlos you could say which is
that um the human um breeds with another
human and then produces um it survives
and reproduces okay yeah
and so that's recursive in the sense so
that the humans made and then the human
procedure calls on itself to make
another human
yes in the process of mitosis you know
cellular division
two things are made out of one so
replicates okay but you also have this
process that precedes it where two
things come together
man and woman come together and and mate
and then the dna is actually combined
right one strand from each and then from
that we get a
basically a one cell which then divides
repeatedly
from one thing into many
yeah so is that what you mean yeah and
so then would then infinite
potentialities
operator be this telic recursive process
to actualize the potential
yes
we could say that yes
so like you know
you know what an operator is of course
i mean that's very simple
just something that operates on
something else
so
yeah so then humans could be seen as
said italic recursive operator
that's right that's right okay
so then
our nature being this infinite potential
and then
in the process of actualizing that
tolesis telesis the actualization of
that
uses the human operator
the body as the operator as the sensor
as the sensor control you can divide
reality into three levels
primary secondary and tertiary and
basically the telesis from the primary
operator is being apportioned among
secondary operators who then
sense it and control actually configure
themselves as causal patterns to make
things
so
the vehicle
itself is the operator is both
for sensing as well as for
will or for
intentionality yes exactly it's a sensor
controller it actually takes things in
which is sensing that's the input
from the outside world and then it
returns
states external states to the outside
world thus controlling it making things
happen
and then
the
the
reality being information doing worker
telesis doing work
there's a feedback process of the
sensing
and of the
intentionality that plays into the
information so that's all information as
i explained telesis does not do work
okay
okay to do work you've got to move
something through a media
tell us this factorize as creating
content in the medium it actually
generates the media it's not working on
something within a medium
it's generating the medium and
relocating things by rescaling them
within the newly generated me
and the medium is the universe is that
right the medium is yes that's the
medium aspect of the universe okay so
um telesis generates the universe
tells us has to be quantized in order to
generate the universe okay so teleca
quanta generate the universe
okay so tell us this is usually what we
use to describe what the quanta of
telesis are made of in other words what
are they you say well you know tell or
it's all great to talk about tell us
what is the teller made of then you
answer that question by saying telesis
right the telesis is always quantized
it's got into closed systems
systems with various levels of closure
and competent uh
coherence
and so
the things that are actually creating
things are
tellers
that once again are sensor controllers
they take the universe they take the
universe in
and then they acquire that using a plan
or something that they want to happen
which then takes the data that is
received from the outside universe and
rearranges it or organizes it into
causal patterns that actually bring
those things about
cool
cool
so
so it's it's fair to say then that the
the universe is the tool that we use to
actualize infinite potential
the universe is not a tool the universe
is ultimate reality which is
some people refer to it as god some
people would refer to it as the one
monad
right
but this is but this is one design
format right a universe is a is one
design format
okay design format let me think about
that for a second uh the universe is
basically something that exists unto and
for itself it can't be
it can be a tool for itself
yeah right it can be a tool for you and
me you know to live our lives and to
actually have experience in the sense
that we're parts of it and therefore the
universe is doing it for itself
all right what we can't say is that
telesis is a tool
it's not telesis is the demonic
substrate of reality and it is something
that is ultimate it has that kind of
ultimacy to it
so we've got to make sure that we
understand
it's just a set of priorities on how
things happen you want to
in the ctmu you don't
have causation in the ordinary since
you've got some
medicalization that actually distributes
over entire timelines it's a whole new
perspective it's hard to learn how to
think in ctne terms
now basically it's the way my mind works
as opposed to the minds of most other
people i can understand how their minds
work and what their picture looks like
people have a hard time understanding
what the ctmu picture
looks like you actually got to use terms
in a different way got to understand the
structure or the medicine tax
as it were before you can understand how
the terms are properly used
so we're just we're just we're having a
little bit of
a communication problem because of the
way we're using the terms you've
obviously developed the mastery of some
ctnu terms but the way they fit together
can be tricky
follow me
totally yeah and same thing with i would
say other like spiritual and scientific
language as well
even a simple word like mysticism or
yoga can be
not understood properly it just means
becoming one with god or union with god
mysticism is also considered by some to
mean non-duality in the asian sense
right which is just the merging of
things into one
which is precisely as you said
merging with god
yeah
beautiful so
would you say that there's a
a process that um
god goes through that sentience goes
through where there's like the illusion
of
separation and that then there's a
remembrance of oneself as the universe
as god
yes you could phrase it that way um
there is uh there is this remembrance in
terms of regressing to the one
you can sort of remember what what what
it is like some of the criteria that god
had to face to make everything exist
um so there's there's definitely that
would you say that that's a core
component of the game
that is this process of sort of
falling asleep to
oneself as infinite potential and then
remembering oneself as infinite
potential
yes you could say that but also keep in
mind that we've got to put
definitional constraints on the infinite
we can say okay infinity is you know
unlimited it means something that's
unlimited but if it's totally unlimited
then it obeys no syntactic invariance
that would allow you to express it
so we have to attach constraints to
infinity in order to even understand and
comprehend
right we have to attach finite q to it
this is known in the integral calculus
you've got to you've got to bound your
your indefinite integrals you've got to
have a starting point in point boundary
conditions in order to actually
actualize things and make them make them
comprehensive
right
so this is what we have to do
cool so you said that
there's a monic substrate one substrate
that's right and that's what um talesis
tell us this is yes tell us this is one
way to express the fact that there is a
monarch
substrate to reality that basically
reality is one thing
yeah right one thing that contains many
things but in order to be one thing it
has to be mine
yeah so that's the way we satisfy that
requirement
cool and then of course the fact that it
is simultaneously many things we use
this relational structure called
syndianesis for that
we use a mapping called immunomorphism
which means multiplex unity or many
things out of one thing yeah it's all
about the myriology
of the uh of the universe and its parts
their relationship
cool
yeah amen so we have a a monic substrate
that is purposeful
in its actualization of infinite
potential yes it actually it implicitly
carries intensive form of intentionality
yeah it's self-actualized it interacts
with itself and basically forms
intentions which it then realizes
that's you can't start from the bottom
up and take a bunch of things and say
well somehow they come together and
somehow they interact with each other
but i can't explain how no you've got to
start with the connectivity you've got
to start with that monic oneness and
then you break that thing up
into the parts that interact with each
other and it provides them with a way of
interaction interacting and relating to
each other yeah see so
so you can't come at it backwards from
the bottom up you've also got to come at
it from the top on the top down
right you've got to do both those things
simultaneously and that's really what
non-duality means it's not what the dual
non-duality means to for a buddhist for
example you know who who has a much more
simplistic way of looking at it but
you've actually got to have both of
these things or if you really want an
explanation of non-duality totally
totally like
totally like a simple very very simple
way is like there is a physical
appearance of a glass of water but it's
also appearing to send to perception
right there's the simultaneous and to
have the perception you not only need
the glass of water you need the medium
in which it is embedded in other words i
have to be able to see the glass i have
to be able to see the boundaries of the
glass and i have to be able to see where
the glass is not i have to see the
absence of that glass in the surrounding
medium that's the only way that i can
identify
that's why telesis has to factorize
itself into content and medium
right and this is irreducible you can't
quantize reality any more than that okay
it can't get any simple yeah you can't
say well on one hand we have states over
here and the medium over there no you've
got to relate those two things and the
only way to do that is on the quantum
problem
cool
and so that plays deeply into
entanglement
this simultaneity the entanglement of
perception with the object
yes
when you quantize reality in that way
basically they're quantized together the
object and the the
observer they're all together totally
they're united on the quantum level
this idea that you can take quanta of
different things and then bring them
together what are you bringing them
together in
i mean what is that what kind of
assumption is that okay well i've got
all these different things and i'm
bringing them together in what in what
medium are you bringing them together
what must the structure of that medium
be in order for you to have the ability
to bring observer and
percept and recipient together in a
perception what must that medium be
and that's what the ctmu answers
it's rather elaborate as i'm sure you're
a word you have to have a meta formal
system and then you get into something
called quantum meta mechanics and of
course you've got the simulation
self-simulation of reality
as a function of
all of the considerations we've
discussed so far
so is there you know it gets gets rather
complicated this is mathematical
metaphysics this is not the kind of
metaphysics that you may be used to
okay where people get together and it's
you've got a
nebulosity over here and they've got an
ambiguity over here
and you know they kind of get very
touchy-feely about it in the ctmu
everything is logical and mathematical
you've got to take these ambiguities and
these touchy-feely things and organize
them mathematically
so that's what the ctmu is about this is
the problem that we have we've got to
understand reality but we can't properly
relate to reality we have to know how we
relate to it otherwise we're never going
to have the perfect world we want
okay we got to learn this then we've got
to work to achieve the kind of world we
want using that information
ctmu is meant to bring us bring
everybody this information cause kind of
mass awakening and tell people who they
are and what reality is how they relate
to reality
right that's the purpose
cool that's the cdmu tell us
nice
yeah
i would concur that there's quite a bit
of ambiguity
in the normal dialogues that happen
across the world about the nature of
reality and it's exciting um to have a
a mathematical logical
um
precise
way of
sharing with people um what is um the
nature
and yeah and then and then that leads to
like you were describing that leads to
basically mastery over reality and
um having abundance in basic needs being
met and actualization of everyone's
potential
that's right we have to understand how
what reality is in order to get what we
want out of it and we have to understand
how we relate to it to understand how we
do that
it's really right on the ground floor
and all these scientists and
materialists who say well metaphysics is
impossible we can't really achieve that
kind of of knowledge these people are
saying well we can never achieve the
kind of world we want
it's
it's rotten i mean there's nothing
truthful about it okay it's dualism it's
the idea that we're somehow separate
from the universe it exists totally
separately from us we can never know it
completely because we're just imposing
our own mental preconceptions on it so
we can never really develop the
relationship that we want to have with
reality that's what they're all saying
and a lot of these people out there that
are trying to actually characterize the
nature of reality labor under this
pathetically wrong assumption
so the ctmu is meant to correct that as
well
you follow me
yeah there's um
the all the ambiguity ctmu is aiming to
help correct
yes
there's there are a lot of
you know there are a lot of just plain
erroneous assumptions and oversights
that even very accomplished scientists
and mathematicians
uh
labor hunter like separation
like like the nature of separation
that's right and what it takes to
overcome it and how it actually you know
how we actually relate to the world we
see these separations we we see the
separation between ourselves and the
world how do we get over that what is
that what brings everything together as
john wheeler put it why why
one world out of many in other words in
other words we all have our own separate
world how do they come together into one
world
okay it's about how we figure that out
that's what the ctm uses the structure
of that meriology that overall
relationship between us
so we are
the one
actualizing infinite potential using
universe
body
etc
well
yes but as i say once again when you say
we are using okay and
and you know we are the one
we're overlooking important distinctions
they're distinctions of level
distinctions of type
right that we have to take account of in
other words the first thing that
somebody says if you say well
you know we're god you know each of us
is god they're gonna say well then why
can't you just make anything happen just
like this
okay you're hungry why don't you have a
hamburger in front of you right like
that okay if you're god
okay so you have to come up with all of
the distinctions and all the structure
that separates you from the
actualization of that wish
which is namely to eat a hamburger
okay
and that's what that's what metaphysics
is all about it's all about explaining
how
intention becomes fact
right and in the ordinary view of the
universe there is no such thing as
intention okay there are only facts and
intentions at best supervene on the
facts and there's some kind of illusion
in and of themselves all right on the
other hand what you seem to be seeing
and what a lot of people actually
believe is that the facts are the
illusions and they're coming from
something deep
some underlying
what the ctmu says is that both of those
things are happening
totally right they have to be they have
to be
there's no separation between fact and
intention or between physicalism and
consciousness no ultimate separation no
yeah it's all the same but it's but it's
a useful distinction to make
um to serve us in different ways
until we start addressing the big
questions yeah okay practical questions
like okay how do we do this how do we do
that what do we want here
okay
yes we have to separate those things and
it's often very useful for us to do so
but
you want to start addressing the big
questions what is reality where did it
come from what is life what is
consciousness now you've got to get
metaphysical
now you need the mathematical mechanics
of the ctmu to put all that together
anybody who tells you any different
really doesn't know what he or she is
talking about
it's as simple as that
yeah and we could say that
the different concepts and ideas that
are
within ctmu
could be
brought forth also
um through other
similar concepts or ideas that are just
called different words
yes well the way we the way i usually
phrase that is that
all of these ideas have value
everybody comes up with great ideas all
the time the object is to interpret them
in one unifying framework yeah so the
ctmu is designed to be that unifying
framework or foundational language
in which all of these other insights as
great as they are can be interpreted
together so that conflicts and paradoxes
don't arise among them
yep
beautiful
i like how you said that
when we say we are the one or we are god
that
the first sort of distinction
or little flag or asterisks to plant
there is that well
um if you are then manifest a hamburger
right now
um yeah i like that it's very simple one
um
and
and then we could say that well you know
in
200 years 300 years when we're closer to
the star trek future
that we can use this
mass energy equivalence to go ahead and
turn
a pure hamburger
right in front of us as needed
so
we are approaching said
ability
well we're not necessarily approaching a
mass synthesizer that
you can actually just feed generic
molecules into and it will produce a
hamburger
we may be more than a couple hundred
years away from that but the universe is
what does that
and the thing that is confusing about it
is that the universe does make it
possible for us to get what we want
but it's not quite as easy as it looks
because you know
the universe is a complex place that's
part of what makes it so satisfying
to us i mean here we are surviving in it
and we're actually
getting things done despite all of its
complexities
so the complexity is part of what we
have to accept it's a part of life
right
but in order to deal with that
complexity
we have to understand what it is
right
what it is and how it emerges
or emanates into the world
that's the important thing
yep
in other words when you want a hamburger
you know
you don't have any money you go get the
job you make a little bit of money you
put the money in your pocket you go down
to mcdonald's and you buy your hamburger
then you eat the hamburger okay
so
there it is it's just there's a few
steps in there designed to accommodate
the complexity of the universe
even if we never get to a hamburger
synthesizer
nevertheless the universe is making it
possible for us to satisfy this
intention you see
yeah
cool so then part of the
the shift into
abundance and
and maximizing our potential is
to
have a more decentralized or
or a universalized ability to manifest
intention
yes
if everybody had uh if everybody was
highly intelligent
and wanted to play along with each other
by the rules
according to the golden rule shall we
say um the world would be a much better
place
as it happens however the world the
current tendency is towards
centralization the centralization of
wealth and power and now we've got this
tiny little handful of no goods
that are basically trying to tell
everybody else what to do as they
accumulate all the wealth and all the
power for themselves
all right that's not an ideal world at
all actually
that
negates the entire purpose of the
universe it kills the point
right so we need to
spread things around we need to have
more of what is called individualism
decentralization as you put it uh
instead of centralization
see
everybody has to take responsibility for
human destiny it can't just be put in
the hands of a few filthy rich oligarchs
you see
those who look upon everybody else as an
animal or some kind of a of a stimulus
response machine or a consumer automaton
okay we've all got to take
responsibility we can't just dump it in
the lab some filthy rich you know
oligarch who then is going to do things
his way and then when we're dissatisfied
with the results and we certainly will
be because his interests come first
all right then you know
there's no point in complaining about
that we've all got to take
responsibility i've got to become highly
intelligent intelligent
educate ourselves to that effect learn
what reality is learn what we are what
we are learn how to cooperate with each
other and then everybody gets what they
want
see
that can be done that that telesis can
be fulfilled within the universe
okay but
humanity human destiny cannot be
fulfilled with this centralization we're
going to have you know one planetary
global government you know with this
bunch of you know these people live in
bubbles they don't understand what it's
like to live in the real world we can't
have a bunch of creatures like that
telling us what to do all the time
all right that takes away our freedom
can no longer actualize ourselves as we
would otherwise do right because they're
constraining everything we do
okay they're controlled junkies they're
control freaks who are telling us you
know do this do that don't do that do
this
you know how it is
i mean people need their freedom right
we inherit freedom from the one
from god
so naturally we want to be able to use
it
you tell me how some of these
uh
potent dates these oligarchs fit into
that
you want to do what joe biden tells you
to do
i mean i don't i don't you know
i don't i don't see any sign that joe or
any of the rest of these people are as
smart as i am or even as good as i am i
don't want to do what they say i don't
regard them as being good enough or
smart enough to be calling the shots
right so we have to everybody has to
take individual responsibility and
that's a big look we've got
responsibilities
and then as a function of those
responsibilities then we have rights and
we have true freedom as a result of that
you follow me
yeah
for sure this is one of uh
i would say
um society's favorite
conversations right now which is the
decentralization or the universalization
of power and freedom right but it can't
be done without responsibility
most of these people for example
especially the radical left you see that
a lot of these people
you know
to hell with authority you know we're
going to have you know power to the
people and
and the people are going to own the
means of production and let's have
communism and i realized that communism
really plays right back into the hands
of the elite you've got a centralized
you know party apparatus and then you've
got these
high party officials that basically own
everything and control everything
they are nothing but proxies for the
capitalistic elite
okay these people don't understand that
in order to have the kind of world we
want it needs to be some kind of a a
platonic paradise where everybody is
rational everybody understands everybody
has compassion everybody has empathy for
everyone else everyone is obeying the
golden rule people are actually out
there getting a job people are
incentivized all of these things are
necessary to have that kind of world
they don't realize that
they think well i'm just going to sit
back there's plenty of money they can
just print it up so i'm going to collect
the money no i don't have to do anything
that he's not doing and so nothing gets
produced and when nothing gets produced
nobody enjoys himself
right
i mean you know the hamburger we were
talking about that's got to be produced
there's not just going to be a
matter synthesizer that makes it for you
anytime soon
so people actually have to be willing to
do their parts they're gonna have moral
responsibility and they've got to
actually be able to
get their hands dirty get out skin their
knuckles and produce things and that's
what not what we have right now we've
got a bunch of people who think you know
these male-educated you know especially
gets worse with every generation there's
more of this bubble thinking this idea
that well mom and dad never had to work
they had bucks and i'm going to live
that way too i'm going to speculate for
a living just like mom and dad and i'm
not actually going to do anything that's
for the little people you can't run a
world that way
even people that are smart that have all
kinds of ability they have to get out
and work too and i don't just mean
speculating and making phone calls and
giving orders to other people i mean
actually working
you know
i mean i had to work all my life
i'm reputed to be one of the smartest
people alive and i had to get out there
and bust my knuckles i did all kinds of
hard work for a living from being a
cowboy to a construction worker to being
a bar bouncer okay but all these little
dwarfs are too good for that you see
well we're owed we deserve paradise so
we're going to get it right now and
here's how we're going to get it we're
going to take power away from everybody
who has it and give it to ourselves
it ain't that easy you know
it's not that easy
you understand that right
of course you do
yeah there's no
there's no um
like shortcuts to the actualization of
the fullest potential of the individual
and of the collective and
the the hard work that the blood sweat
and tears that goes into the process is
exactly
why the one is doing this it's not for a
effortless frictionless smooth ride
but it's for the polarity and for all of
the insanity um that unfolds on the
roller coaster joyous and treacherous at
the same time um
it's a law of being there is no
satiation there is no satisfaction
without effort if you take away all the
effort then what is satisfaction
if you immediately get everything that
you want just by thinking about it
you know basically it comes down to the
difference between between
sadness and happiness if you don't know
what sadness is you have no way of
knowing what happiness is you've got to
have that contrast between the two
sadness is the absence of happiness
you've got to experience that before you
actually know what happiness is you've
got to experience some effort before you
know what seychelles
okay you've actually got to get out
there and work before you can really
enjoy the fruits of your labor and the
labor of others
and this is what people forget they
think they can have half the equation
well i'm going to have the rewards but
with no work going into it
okay where there is no effort where
there's no risk there is no reward but
there's no expenditure of anything
you don't get anything back
it's simple
nice
yeah
so this also plays really interestingly
into the future
uh paradigm of this
replicator or this matter synthesizer
where if you can just think your
intention and have the
manifestation in reality
that
where is then the effort precisely
remember what i was saying about abusive
content in order to identify the water
glass that you were holding up there
it's got to be in a medium and you've
got to be able to see the glass see its
boundary and then see the absence of
that glass outside
in order to experience happiness you've
got to be able to see
the outside of that happiness you've got
to be able to see where it's not happy
and you can make them make the
distinction between the two
all right but that distinction is
impossible if you don't know what
sadness is if you don't know what
unhappiness is cool once everything is
once everything is pure happiness
where's the happiness you've simply got
a zero okay the pointer that used to
point toward happiness has now gone to
zero because there's no other side and
then that means this side disappears as
well
are there different
are there different flavors of happiness
though
sure there are as many as you can
imagine well then yeah but there but
there is effort associated with each one
in order to achieve it there has to be
you've got to put something out or you
don't get anything back
all right that's what all these all
these rich people who are out there
think everything comes easy you know
nobody has to you know complain
these right-wingers out there working on
farms and working with animals they all
suck
you know because basically this could be
a big paradise where everybody just gets
what he wants right now
how ass
how utterly absurd
is this what they're being taught in
college
if so i'm really really glad i never won
nice
yeah now we have to make our uh our own
um
sort of education
in life uh it's called uh
the school of hard knocks school of hard
knocks yeah nice
what's the what's the word um auto
didact yeah um
yeah yes but of course you know that
takes discipline and not everybody has
discipline there are a lot of people who
are just you know not equipped to uh to
really be auto diabetics
most people i guess maybe you have to
put them in some kind of educational
environment where they're being pushed
constantly to learn this memorize that
right but then they become nothing but
parents and that's what the university
system produces now a bunch of little
parents to get up and just regurgitate
whatever they were told by their
so-called instructors
in this place and it's the world is
deteriorating rapidly because of this
consists of a bunch of these these
little squawking parrots
can't produce anything have no original
thoughts
you understand i mean you can't run away
but one time that's not what the world
is okay i wrote the world there's a
rough and tumble place and we're in it
and we're gonna have to live and we're
gonna have to skin our knuckles a little
bit and then we get something back out
isn't it wonderful when we do okay but
this idea that you can just live in your
little bubble you know all walled off
from all the unpleasantness outside and
just continue to you know speculate and
get your money through the bubble you
know and get whatever you want i mean
this is
just ridiculous
i don't understand how people could
possibly believe this
all right but a lot of them do an
increasing number do believe it and
that's pathological
that's a so that's a social pathology
that we have got to break out of
immediately because it's killing us
i remember writing
maybe around two years ago or so i was
just really excited about learning about
how there were 100 billion or so people
before us that had lived and died to
build this abundant world that we live
in
and i wrote something about like us
today where many of us are
very blessed because we're not farming
but we're on twitter
and that plays really well into these
these
uh like the classic people that you see
at i don't know
whatever side of the political spectrum
they're on but they're on twitter and
they're sending their little
messages and stuff like that and virtue
signaling yeah
yeah and and we we all know that when
you sort of take a break from what you
look like on the internet
and richard dawkins is called this
extended phenotype people are really
obsessed with how their extended
phenotypes being portrayed in the social
space and like you were saying virtue
signaling and whatnot if you sort of
take a break from that
and you turn inward and you
really
feel into like who am i what am i what
is i
that type of thing that's where you get
to this monic substrate that's when you
that's a that's exactly right and that
extended phenotype is probably the best
idea that richie dawkins ever had for
himself the thing is these people that
are that are that are trying to
implement the extended phenotype
are doing it in these extremely
artificial media i mean that's not
really what the environment is that's
not not the natural environment that
they're feeding back into it's a totally
artificial environment that has no
natural reality to it whatsoever so
that's where the extended phenotype goes
bad
right
nice
yeah because when you're just sending a
message a little tweet
um
you're playing in some
sphere that
has so many perverse incentives
in it
whereas if you're you know if you're
turned inward and you're there
in
like pure service to another human like
face to face um completely different
feeling than being behind a phone or a
computer and trying to prove your point
totally actually yeah and actually
getting out into the real world with you
know a shovel or a pic or an axe
you know that also makes a big
difference too
you know this this this digital
existence where everybody just sits at a
keyboard
taps away all day if you don't know what
real
existence is all about actually what it
takes to really produce things then and
you think that this is what life is
you have a a
terribly skewed picture of reality
that's what so many of these people have
especially
like like the phones and the computers
that they are using um
or like the electricity that powers them
and powers their home and powers their
fridge and their stove and washing
conception no conception of what makes
any of it work
yeah that type of thing i would love for
that turn inward
to
the one to also be a turn towards how
um the physical works um
and how to
make basic needs
um available and universalized and
actualize all of our potential because
the the contrast like we were just
describing is when you're just behind a
keyboard or a phone and you're just
trying to prove your point on the
internet and so
that's the contrast and that's
just the simple turn in word um and the
turn towards being more and more in
service service to others
um that's a really that's an interesting
way to look at it but in pure service
others not in a way that's oh i'm going
to serve other people because i want to
be seen or i'm going to serve other
people secretly for myself or
um or i'm gonna serve other people so
that i can be um worthy or that i can
have a greater social presence um these
are many traps that we can fall into um
along the way to prove my point
yeah i mean the the whole thing is so
superficial you know the entire
um information economy has been
perverted to this you know this
this bubble it's a it's a bubble world
where people live in this bubble and
they don't understand what service to
other people is really all about
okay those those farmers that everybody
has taught that all certainly all the
all the liberals and democrats speak
very poorly upon well these are trump
supporters
these farmers i mean what a bunch of
scum look they have to work with their
hands whereas we're college educated you
know we get to sit and tap on our
keyboards all day
that's of course totally
it's entirely negative in its
consequences because these people
actually think
that
tapping on their computer is somehow
being of service to other people it's
not
okay the people who are producing the
food getting out there working with
their hands building things
digging coal out of the mines right
these are people who are actually
constructively involved in helping other
people because they're producing things
that other people need
right you're just sitting you know being
some sort of a god forsaken little troll
on your computer you're not producing
anything that anybody needs
right you're just feeding your ego you
know do they think i'm
smart do they think i'm good looking you
know am i going to be an effective
influencer
i mean come on
uh who has who has any respect for
people like that
i don't understand how you can
all right but then again i grew up among
you know real people who are out working
in the real world
when you don't get a college education
when you have no college degree you have
no choice but to go out there and work
in menial occupations with people who
actually have to produce things so you
develop more respect for them
that's what this society now lacks it
lacks any respect for people that
actually know what it takes to produce
the things that other people need to
live
right
yeah because you're gonna have to go to
the grocery store and get what the
farmer made
um
that's correct the farmer that's correct
your people are not dependent on your
tweet
right people couldn't give a hoot less
about your tweet
they can't they can't eat it you know it
doesn't provide them with shelter they
can't drink it right they can't even
watch it like a football game okay
there's no excitement in it it's just
your private little ego thing that
you're doing in order to be better
perceived what you think is better
perceived by other people but if those
other people are not worthwhile i mean
if they don't really have worthwhile
perspectives then what does that work i
love that the private little ego thing
it's a great way to put it yeah it's
basically what it's all about these days
with most of these most of these people
that's great so good and so then we
could say that the one of the
most accelerating ways to actualize our
potential is to pop the bubble of the
private little ego thing
how are you going to do that
okay
how are you how are you going to pop
these people think that they can go out
and you know ride in the streets and
burn buildings and loot and they think
that they can
scream you know and run around beating
people up if they for instance have a
some kind of a demonstration in favor of
gun rights or something like that you
know running and beating them up is the
thing to do i mean these people are not
it is not a viable strategy if everybody
does what they do the world would
collapse in turmoil let me give you an
example right that you wouldn't have
anything left after not very much time
at all literally let me give you an
example so you ask like how do we pop
the
little private ego separation bubbles
so
it's actually
like already happening
like cosmologically it's already
happening it's like a
a feature of of reality is the awake
process and so
when you look at a very simple
catalyst it can be something like one of
the people that we were just talking
about
for them to see
someone else
that has a greater degree of equanimity
patience
love
wisdom discernment when when they see
that type of person when they see that
type of energy
even though they may not themselves
right away oh i'm gonna make that
transition as well um
that
it's like the seed has been planted
and that it does get watered gently over
time well it's nice when it does
sometimes the seed gets planted there's
fertile ground in which to plant it and
sometimes it gets watered and nurtured
and people wake up but there are a great
number of people out there who aren't
waking up
okay they can see it all around them
they can see that there are people who
actually perform necessary functions
you know for their own existence but
they don't appreciate that
they're phenomenally unappreciative
they've been to university and they know
that real really the cool thing is to
have a lot of money you know and live in
a really nice house and you know get
things and have lots of stuff and those
people you know the ones that are out
there producing the food and everything
you know they're not with it at all you
know who wants to be like them i mean
they're sweating you know they're
grunting as they're out there working
and producing the food who wants to be
like that this is the way a lot of them
think and you can show them any amount
of sacrifice on the parts of such people
and they don't care
it's like water off a duck's back
okay and those people are a problem
we've got many many of those people out
there
all right
they have nothing but contempt for the
people who actually do things
you know that
it's cool to be a socialist or a
communist now but this is basically the
backbone of socialism everybody gets out
there and does his share everybody gets
out there and works these people have no
idea what that means
they think well it's basically about
writing in the streets screaming and
yelling you know accusing other people
of not doing their part
okay maybe we'll you know become uh you
know members of the new politburo when
the new socialist utopia springs up but
they're not they're not going to be
they're not you know
they're not there's not enough room in
that little philippe borough for all of
these
these liberals who think that they're
going to be in it okay they're not going
to be in it somebody is going to say
okay well here's a shovel
you go over there and you dig that ditch
and you do it pretty quick otherwise
guess what
you know it's going to be like the
killing fields
all right and we'll just eliminate you
because this is how a lot of them talk
too they've been talking that way for a
long time
you know communism is not a good thing
it killed between 100 and 200 million
people in the 20th century alone
okay and these little kids don't
understand that i guess it doesn't get
mentioned
in the classrooms they attend in the
universities
that they pay so much to go to that
their parents pay for them to go to
it's one of the most important
statistics i agree totally
so it really feels like 200 million
people
yeah horribly killed murdered totally on
many occasions tortured yes i would say
that's something that we can't exactly
ignore but they're all ignoring and we
can also shift more of our
civilizational conversation towards
decentralization technologies
so the slow biomimicry of how plants and
mycelium communicate underground to
basically embed that into our social
contracts
and so there is a big shift that's
happening um also with that but just
collective intentionality towards
decentralization is another big way um
to actualize our potential yes but of
course that potential has to be realized
in the forms of these people picking up
garden spades and getting out there in
the dirt and planting the seeds and
growing the food and understanding how
that feels
all right well no you don't know
everybody can't be a big shot that's
pointing at this and that telling other
people to do that
yeah they look at the people who think
that they're entitled to live that kind
of life and you actually measure their
iqs and you see what they've got
upstairs and you actually take a look
and see what they've accomplished in
their lives you realize these people
aren't qualified to tell anybody else to
do anything
what are they thinking
they they're thinking they're going to
be in you know the cat bird seat and
they're going to be you know calling the
shots and telling other people to do
work you know when in reality they know
nothing
they've lived in this little bubble all
their lives and they don't understand
what it's actually like to get anything
done
and that's who's trying to run the world
right now and that's why the world is
falling apart that's why our economy is
going straight to hell
yeah two two points there blessed
yeah two points there one of them is
that um not all of the 2 200
billionaires around the planet are
um
total chumps um
and they aren't yeah well can you can
you point out can you point out a really
productive billionaire
has got not worked with his hands and
actually produced something as opposed
to hiring other people from the best
colleges and universities and pointing
at certain things that they want done
can you name a billionaire like that
i've been trying to i've been looking a
long time myself for a really valuable
you know human being who is also a
billionaire
yeah and i'm coming up dry i'm coming up
empty okay because that's not what kind
of people these people are they're
sociopathic youtube narcissistic sure
sure i mean they've got they've got the
dark tetra going forward you understand
that's why they're billionaires i don't
i don't disagree that the that what
appears as the majority um have the
intentionality of the
like the collection of
um
uh materialistic possessions
um in order to
flaunt a
social status
i definitely don't disagree with that
and even furthermore i definitely don't
disagree with how there's a
an oligarchical civilizational dynamic
that's happening with a control
substrate for sure
um
but um um simultaneously i don't see it
only as this was the second point i
don't see it as only grabbing um
a shovel and gardening or to produce
food locally i know that that was likely
just an analogy that that you were using
um but i actually see like the person
that is um working like on the computer
but somebody that is um creating like
the decentralized fabric or social
contracts through you know tech
infrastructure i see that as somebody
that is also doing the work you think
tech infrastructure
is decentralizing anything
well
my last interview the one that i had
with kurt jamungal was cancelled on all
apple mobile devices
as far as i'm as far as i know it's the
first video that has that has happened
to oh what they're doing what these big
tech people
by creating their decentralized
platforms is made it possible for
themselves to censor anybody who's
saying anything they don't like and
that's what they're doing
so now is that a positive thing so just
to clarify because i didn't know this so
apple um podcasts itunes they did not um
allow the public all of their mobile
devices the ones that use the youtube
app have blocked my last video
all right
that's it i mean this kind of thing
happens to me all the time i've been
de-platformed several times hounded off
various you know forms that are run by
people who simply don't share my
philosophical perspective so it's very
important for you to understand that
these techy billionaires that are that
are you know allegedly bringing all this
decentralization
it's not decentralized at all
they have central the central power of
censorship over these media and
platforms that they run and they're
using
they're using to the detriment of all of
us
point one out who isn't i mean you just
show me the billionaire i mean i
understand that some guys are getting
are in the field and they're trying to
make a dent
right
but they're not really succeeding
because they're not getting the
cooperation of the other billionaires
out there
right
that's the problem we've got now
they've had it too good for too long
they did too little work they got too
much of a return they got too much
reward and now they think that they know
it all and they're the ones who should
be calling the shots forever and telling
you what to say and think
and among the things that they don't
want you to say or think
among those things are the ctmu
all right i've seen this happen now for
about 30 years
they want you to have an artificially
messed up view of reality and yourself
because that's what suits them
they can continue to run the world that
way if you're not smart enough to stop
them if you don't know what reality is
or how it works you're going to let them
continue to get away with this that's
why these oligarchs are are
consolidating all the money and all the
power and every tinier handful of them
have more and more of the world's wealth
you think they're going to give it back
who's going to make them
figure it out
yeah so this is where my excitement
around the vision of decentralization
and universalism
acts as a
forcing function for the
um
the sharing of power the sharing of
actualization of intention
the
um
the dismantling of the control fabric um
the matrix system
um
so anyway yeah that was really fun we we
definitely um passed a solid amount of
time and energy on that and it was
really beautiful
um but i i'm very positive and
optimistic about um decentralization
universalization and the sharing of
power and the sharing of actualizing
intention
across the world why are you optimistic
in light of the events over the last two
years well it's not that i don't know
the data of the other side i do know the
data of the other side so it's basically
you you survey the the landscape of
information
but then for example my intentionality
like we talked about with um the sensor
and the intention being the human
vehicle of the one that my intention is
towards the positivity is towards the
optimism is towards the universalization
and decentralization absolutely yes but
is it going to be allowed to happen
because that
universalization that we're talking
about is being choked off
all right there is a
better or not there's a small group of
people who want all the wealth and all
the power are they going to let
the telic recursion of the rest of
humanity come to fruition
and give humanity what it wants or are
they simply going to continue with their
ongoing agenda of accumulating more of
the wealth and power for themselves
this is a problem so yeah if you
mechanize things the way they've
mechanized things you eventually choke
off telegraph you stop the
intentionality the positive
intentionality of other people from ever
coming to fruition
that's what they're doing
okay so if there's no means to stop them
all right then we've got a problem and i
think it's necessary for us to
understand the nature of the problems
that we face
cool agreed and it feels like
one of the means is the um meeting of
basic needs worldwide um is the
um
the decentralizing away um from um
centralized banks and decentralizing
away from um centralized energy
infrastructure as well
exactly things like that things like the
money supply have to be decentralized
but if you get up to decentral in other
words you know like blockchain for
example
you know
not even blockchain is foolproof in that
respect because it can be
somebody can pull the plug on the
internet i mean there's an internet kill
switch all of these governments have
their fingers on that kill switch
they're not going to they're only going
to let decentralization proceed so far
before they use that switch
right you know what is that they're very
jealous they sent the the international
banking community is very jealous of its
power over money
okay they're not going to let it go just
like that
how do you stop how do you take the
power of money away from if you were to
start printing if you were gonna say
okay
i've just invented the atlas doll okay
we're gonna we're gonna we're all gonna
trade in atlas dollars now and i'm gonna
take you know the money monopoly away
from these these oligarchs and you know
i'm gonna you know have my own little
share of it here so we're gonna use
atlas dollars you've got to get other
people to accept the atlas stones in
reality what's going to happen is that
is the
the bureau of the treasury you know the
the
the uh
all kinds of federal agencies will
converge on you and land on you and
accuse you of counterfeiting and
undermining the very fabric of reality
by printing your own kind of money
right
and nobody else in the world is going to
accept it and with this decentralized
economy where we're getting goods and
services from all over the world
okay you're not going to be able to get
what you need because nobody else is
going to accept your money
for example in another country
right
so how do you decentralize that when
they don't want to let go
nice
well these are the problems that we face
i mean i'm a realist i like to be you
know realistic about our prospects how
do we get to the kind of world that we
want well we have obstacles now the
obstacles are huge
we need to take extraordinary action
to make any progress at all
people have to realize that
intentionality is a large part of it
having those positive thoughts and
envisioning the great kind of future
that we want that's a huge part of it
we've also got to address the obstacles
okay it's going to be risky and it's
going to be dirty but we have to do it
yeah
i wish there was a way to sugarcoat it
but there ain't
you know we have all kinds of of history
that we can look back at and see you
know these parasitic divergences have
happened many times in the past and they
never lead anywhere good eventually they
lead to the dissolution of society and
foreign invaders come in and take
everything over and then things are
rebuilt on a different footing someplace
else we're out of someplace else there's
no place else to go and start over
okay so this is a juncture in human
history that's very important to us
okay it's a singularity we're either
gonna have a human singularity where
everybody takes responsibility for human
destiny but we're going to have another
kind of singularity the tech singularity
with all of these oligarchs owning all
of the technology and controlling it and
if you let them put the technology in
you
they're going to control you as a
function
see what i mean those are all questions
that mankind has never been faced with
before we've never had to deal with that
kind of question we need to deal with
that kind of question right now
or it's going to be too so
from from how i see it chris i see it i
see it like this
the more that
the individual
turns inward which is usually catalyzed
by their basic needs being met
that
then the individual figures themselves
out as the one
and when they figure themselves out as
the one then they
every action that they have becomes
infused with that knowledge they become
a gnostic being
and then they work on the purification
of their action to be more and more
aligned with pure service to the
collective
and in that process what happens is
their
actions
end up
being meeting the basic needs of other
selves or around upgrading the energy
infrastructures to be more decentralized
more universalized ownership
um
not always that way but i would say that
the spiritual realizations
trigger
the external um materialistic
universalization
yes unless the universalization is being
impeded by people that already own all
the energy infrastructure the monetary
infrastructure and everything else it's
those impediments that we have to deal
with other than that everything that you
said is perfectly there
cool so so then there's almost a
um
for you there's a distinguishing of
dealing with the impediments and for me
um there's not so much of distinguishing
or
between that rather that the awakening
of the individual creates more and more
of the planetary collective if it is
allowed to if it is allowed to
okay once again if it is not being
obstructed if it is allowed to happen
then yes we are the way reality is
structured it will happen
okay but we've got a problem now
too much of the wealth too much of the
power has become centralized that
centralization resists decentralization
that's what you call an impediment
this is what we have to cope with we let
it go too far
okay this mass awakening that we need
it took too long and these
forces of centralization are moving too
much faster
you follow me
and then this is a real world situation
i'm not just talking about a pair of
perspectives yours and mine
i'm talking about facts
if you take a look at it there are
certain what we're living in now is a
system called monopoly capitalism
okay
not only is all the money and all the
power centralized but the markets are
controlled
all right grocery stores all over the
country are drying up right now because
the the food supply chain is drying up
okay
is that because what is that because of
it's because the people that own the
companies that produce the food are
choking off the supply
they're doing it so that they can
basically starve the public into
submission
people are already complaining about it
they're going to be complaining about it
a lot more
you know when you take a look at people
like you know george soros you know
klaus schwab
they don't fool around
okay these are not the little angel
perched on your shoulder saying well you
better move in the other direction
they're determined that you don't move
in the other direction they're going to
take control of you right and so you
have to realize this in order to resist
understand what reality is and then you
can do something about this so part of
our positive intentionality is going to
have to be negatively manifested we're
going to have to remove the obstacles
you want to get the point a from point b
and there's a big rock
in your way you either have to figure
out a way around it or you've got to
move the rock
so that is what we also have to think
about doing it's not just the positive
actualization although that is exactly
what the ctmu is about you've also got
this other aspect to deal with
they've mechanized
causation so that now it's not so much
about telic recursion it's about what
they forced to happen
you understand for sure yeah so there's
a natural
force
that is
the cosmos wanting to know itself and to
realize itself and then there's what
appears to be a more unnatural
artificial force which is ego um which
is control
right which is these 2200 billionaires
or whatever you want to call them some
of them are trillionaires of course
they're not on the forbes you know
richest people list but
they're there okay and these people
are used to having everything they want
and they're never satisfied okay they
don't know what it's like to do without
anymore and it takes more and more for
them to even feel as though they're
gaining anything so they're sucking
everything out
that exists that we need
into their own sphere their own
control sphere as fast as they can
and we're
just starting to feel the results it's
going to get worse and worse and worse
so cpmu this is called a parasitic
divergence okay they're basically in
parasite mode these billionaires they
don't work i've worked a lot harder in
my life than they have i've created a
lot more value to human time for
instance the ctmu but they're stopping
me from disseminating my work and
getting it out there well meanwhile
they're fattening like hogs
okay so i look at this and there's just
no offense or butt's about all right we
have a problem it's a bad problem and we
have to solve it it's not going to be
easy and it's not going to be it's not
going to happen overnight but we've got
to think along these lines
while we're while we're positively
imagining what our future should be and
actualizing it using teleconversion the
power of our minds alone of our
intentionality while we're doing that
we're going to have to start dismantling
some of the crap that stands in our way
you see what i mean for sure so for a
long time i thought that the elite were
the kinds of people who you know
basically rational people who were going
to cooperate towards this end let's
restore balance you know that's that's
the way you get a sustainable society is
you restore the balance to things
very few of these people appear to want
to restore that balance they just want
to appear to want to get richer and
richer and richer thusly making society
more asymmetrical and more unbalanced
that's a problem
i'm curious do you feel um
and see
the simultaneity where
everything
that is already unfolding with the one
is already both
perfect and there's also like you
describe this rock of like
centralization and ego that's in the way
so do you see both
at the same time yes i see the
perfection of reality of its overall
structure but i also see the perversion
of that perfection yeah i was just
people who are using their free will
their own free will to bind it in bad
and deleterious ways
yeah i was gonna say you just seem very
polarized um towards the rock um and
i've interviewed people before that sort
of see it both ways in terms of they can
see the perfection and they can see the
rock at the same time and those are very
you know that's high level um
simultaneity that's really high level
consciousness precisely you have to be
able to see both sides
more power to the people that can see
both sides at once totally but if you're
only seeing the positive side you're not
seeing the rock and you're not admitting
to yourself that it needs to be removed
real quick until there's a problem
here's here's what i would what i would
say about that is just that it feels
like your polarization
towards the rock side of it um may be a
little bit um
it feels very aggressive towards that
and i i agree it's very important to
have a insight around the rock of
centralization and ego that's in the way
of the actualization of the universe you
believe in evil atlas do you think
there's such a thing as evil in the
world it sounds to me like
you're like psychoanalyzing me and
saying well okay i'm looking at you now
and what is the aggression in you all
about okay and to do that it almost
seems as though you're distracting
yourself from the idea that there are
any real objective problems out there
that have to be dealt with no no no not
is that accurate no no i wouldn't no no
i wouldn't say that because i have this
i'm like feeling into the collective and
feeling into the universe's intention
and what it feels like is that the it's
like a cosmological
um
it's like a clock in a sense it's like
um yes like you asked the question do i
believe in evil um i believe and feel
that
the manifestation of the entirety of
what we are is a rhythmic interchange
between them
and that um you know very well
symbolized in the taijitsu where you
have the yin and yang but they are
inside of the monism they are inside of
the one
um right yeah and so and so i would say
that um the simultaneity of that is
great like for example chris i've i love
your analysis of the rock and i think
it's really important and many of the
guests that have come on the show have
seen that um and it's really important
the really high level ones but then also
there's this like the rock is embedded
within the perfection of what everything
is and the more that we sort of at a
grassroots level inspire people to
decentralize and to universalize and to
actualize and to meet basic needs and
that type of thing
with our intentionality the rock almost
also naturally um becomes less and less
of an issue
it's not natural
the rock is an artificial construct
you've got a very tiny handful of evil
people who are determined to keep it
right where it is they don't want the
rest of humanity to move that rock
because that would detract from their
wealth and their power and their degree
of control we have to be honest about
what human beings are about human nature
okay not if this this this idea of
positivity of positively imagining our
future
very very important you can't
underestimate the importance of it but
on the other side you also can't
underestimate the importance of a small
handful of no good nicks who are trying
to obstruct that okay
you can't you can't discount one and you
can't say well just naturally
you know the the the teleco recursion
the positive teleconversion of humanity
is going to succeed and it's going to
win in the end well it always wins and
cost
okay and apparently this this tiny
handful of billionaires trillionaires
whatever you want to call it they're
determined to make that cost very very
high
and if they make it too high then we're
not going to make it through the great
filter
the species will actually come to
nothing okay we have to fight to survive
that's what the world of evolution is
that's what that's what that's what
natural selection is all about
every species alive has to fight to keep
itself alive
right and you've got to fight in the
right direction you've got to make your
battles count
okay so that's what we have to do too
and now the enemy is largely within
having defeated all these external
enemies now we've got an enemy that has
sprung up within humankind itself
interesting cool so so you're speaking
to
the
the need at a at a metaphysical um
natural selection level
to
um like you said that the the rock has
sprung up the ego the
um separation has sprung up from within
and now
um to polarize towards service to others
towards light towards the one towards
god um towards no separation
towards universalization towards that is
the key we have to polarize very
aggressively towards that
right and that does have to be a touch
of aggression it's not just my
aggression
although i do sometimes feel aggressive
about this situation like it better be
it had better be everybody's aggression
because that's the only way it's going
to succeed i can sit here and feel as
aggressive as i want to and nothing's
wrong
people have to understand the problem so
that they too
become aggressive about solving it
that's the only way it's going to get
solved
cool
cool nice that was a that was a fun
like second hour or so on on that
subject i i thought that was really
interesting i think we've been going for
about two hours it's very close to two
hours
yeah a little longer
the first was uh more about um the
nature of reality
well it was funny because the second was
also about the nature of reality but it
was very um very practical in terms of
what we see at a civilizational level
and less so about um how the one
actualizes infinite potential um using
universes and sensors um in intention
and it's it's quite interesting uh
where we played super cool chris super
cool uh you know the ctmu is very
complex it's not a my it's a mindset
you've actually got to learn you've
actually got to cultivate it in order to
in order to
proportion things in the proper way in
order to get the syntax down
and see my problem is when somebody
talks about metaphysics standard
metaphysics they're using a whole
different syntax that i consider to be
completely inadequate that doesn't make
any sense to me which is why metaphysics
hasn't really gotten anywhere in the
last two or three thousand years
that's why people are still looking back
to uh to hinduism and buddhism and you
know early christianity or the hellenic
period and saying well you know that's
when they figured everything out and
we've done nothing since then and it's
true it's because they're syntactic
blockages the syntax of standard
metaphysics just doesn't support any
kind of
progress
in the field of metaphysics so i haven't
been using that syntax for a long time
i've adopted a new syntax which makes it
hard for me to understand sometimes the
viewpoints of people who use the old
syntax the one that has been proven time
and time again not to work
so that would that would be that's the
way i would characterize my problem
interesting so
when you feel like
um
you weren't being understood it was
because
um you feel like maybe i was coming from
some of the older syntax and you were
coming from some of the newer more
mathematical
syntax right exactly that's that's
and it's it's part of the course i mean
i often feel that way
i have these uh forums that i run and
sometimes you know people that just show
up you know they start using the old
syntax
and i sometimes become impatient because
hey
you know what are you doing here if
you're going to use the or if you insist
on using the old syntax use the new
stuff that i figured out i mean the
papers have been out there for
years many of them so go ahead and read
them and you know familiarize yourself
with that and then come back and we can
have a conversation that's why i
sometimes you know get criticized for
jumping on
people because
you know there's sometimes not that this
is true of you at all i mean i think
you're very easy to get along with but a
lot of people tend to be very
presumptuous about the sufficiency or
the adequacy of the older syntax of
metaphysics that's a mistake because
it's not adequate at all
they actually tend to become a little
bit uh self-righteous about it
like well all the metaphysics the uh of
the last two two thousand years and the
great metaphysicians in academia say and
to me that counts for nothing they're
all using inadequate syntax they have
nothing to say
i mean sometimes they say something
that's valuable and something that's
meaningful but it all has to be
reinterpreted in a system that has the
proper syntax to organize it all and
make it all fit together otherwise it
counts for another
see what i mean
but that's just my problem and we're
trying to get over that by actually
you know making people understand what
the new syntax is they're talking good
sign is people are talking about
non-duality
and you know buddhism and
hinduism and a lot of the old school
stuff and that a lot of that talk is is
productive i think
so they're kind of starting to break out
of the old way of looking at things but
or at least the the western way of
looking at things
but uh nevertheless
there's still room for a group
very interesting so
what i would um also
ask is i've spent um a good amount of
time now publishing visuals around the
nature of reality
a book that i published called high
level perception
um
and more
given these like the show that i host
simulation and all of the different of
direct
messages that i deliver to the audience
along with these interviews
i have these really i have these nice
visuals that i produce around the nature
of reality and so
um
johan wolfgang von guerte has a really
good quote and it goes
metamorphosis
so the caterpillar turning into the
butterfly
and
light prismatically refracted
our
indicators that
the
greatest educational lectures belong in
the artist sphere of work
so
in a sense how i interpret that is that
what i'm doing with these visualizations
of the nature of reality
are things like taking if you take the
one and you look at it like this white
light
prismatically refracted into these seven
dis
seemingly different
levels of consciousness let's say or
levels of perception
that are all
like matroshka dolls
so they're nested within each other
you sort of start at this very red
orangey yellowy to matching the chakras
as has been said
that is a little bit more survival based
or ego based separation based and then
it opens up to this green blue indigo
violet when you reunite with the one
when you awake one and that's recursive
like the oroboros
um so you see
how what's your take on the artistic
side of it the artistic visual side of
it because you're very mathematical
syntactical
what's your take on the artistic on the
visual side of it um being able to
deliver almost potentially a
michelangelo style of deliverance of the
nature into the hearts of people around
the world rather than what seems like
this heavy mathematical one
well there are lots of analogies that i
have used they're you know
quasi-artistic that people could use to
understand ctmu but one of the things
that
that i have to say about works of art
is the one thing that characterizes
great art is the number of different
ways you can interpret it
you will find as many
different interpretations of a good
piece of art as there are people who
look at it
that means that it's very hard to
maintain a stable correspondence okay
between
people
the observers of a work of art and the
work of art itself okay its meaning ends
up being ambiguous because when you add
everybody's opinion of what it means
they tend to cancel out
this is what the mathematics is for you
see it restores that cancellation
okay you've got actually got a
correspondence that you can put your
finger
okay so although i admit the value of
the artistic interpretation aspect
because that's what really engages us
okay bringing all those different
engagements together
that requires logic and mathematics
no defense or buts about it both sides
have their purpose and they totally come
together
totally so basically um the way that i
would bring in your
um mathematical logical side into what i
was just explaining would be well how do
you define the one or the white light
how do you define the prismatic
refraction how do you define the red
orange yellow green blue indigo violet
levels of consciousness or levels of
perception
how do you define those and how do
people shift upwards in them um and then
what is the nature of that cyclic
process that we are
well we define the one as reality which
is
an intention extension coupling our int
equals rx
i've actually written that down
and then that what you just described
with the colors that's a lattice that's
a logic structure called a lattice okay
and moving and that lattice is self dual
which means you can move both up and
down using dual operations
right
something called stone duality you can
do this with you know these mathematical
facts help us organize what you're
talking about into something that
everybody can understand on an
equivalent basis
okay in other words you see a piece of
art you have your own interpretation i
see the same piece of art i have my
interpretation how can we come together
right on what that piece of art actually
is
well it's using
this kind of concept
right concepts like logic lattices and
logical identities and sets that have
extensions and intentions
these are important aspects of us
actually agreeing on what it is we're
looking at
right
now that's what metaphysics that's what
our reality theory has not had everybody
has their own perspective nobody can
come together because there is no common
foundational language for all of them
yeah that's what i've tried to provide
that's what ctmu is it's a common
foundational language with the structure
that we need to all come together about
what it is we're looking at
very cool i feel like you're a role
model and inspiration for me in that
sense of
taking what i've
um distilled as the synthesis of science
and spirituality and making it even more
um
logical and mathematical along with my
artistic and visual side of it
and potentially even um playing more
intimately with uh ctmu um with you and
uh in the longer term as well and seeing
how that unfolds so i would love to
um i'd love to play on this again
potentially
we could do another one of these maybe
at the beginning of next year or
something like that and we could
revisit this as i also make better and
better models that are artistic and that
use of math and logic in them
to also see
and get some of the reflections um from
you about how they look like and whatnot
excellent excellent you know try to do
this with my
my stepfather is a painter he actually
paints pictures that give you a visual
representation of box sonatas and things
like that and there's actually a
mathematical structure there too but
he's got that synesthesia going between
the music and the visuals and i see
that's what you're trying to do and it's
a valuable thing it's very interesting
and of course i would want to help you
do that constructively of course
um and if you have any questions uh that
you would like to ask if any parts of
this interview appear to be uh
inadequate from your point of view by
all means let me know get some more
questions together and even in the short
term i'd be happy to answer them
awesome yeah this has been such a
blessing and such a pleasure this is so
cool
yeah it has been certainly has been yeah
you're really cool and my heart is i'm
with our relationship it's really
beautiful
okay thank you so much and and i
appreciate you too
and uh i look forward to uh future
correspondence and collaboration awesome
and then let me wrap the show also
quickly chris i'll say to our audience
thank you everyone for tuning in we love
you very much we're really grateful we
would love for you to
like the video it helps the algorithm
also subscribe to the channel if you
haven't yet leave us a comment below
with your thoughts on what we discussed
during the episode on what chris was
sharing and also check out the links in
the bio below
you can find the
ctmu.org link in the bio below
and you can also find other ways to
support um chris chris would it be nice
to put your patreon down there is that
the best place for people to support
yes i guess that's as good as any
great cool so we'll have the
chris lagan patreon page yeah there's
also a ctmu page
that gina might have put up i think she
did so yes either of those pages would
be great i've got a lot of good material
on there
it's occasionally little videos you know
little uh little dialogues that we do
plus writing that i do on some of the
deeper aspects of the ctn so by all
means looking
perfect so we'll have the patreon um
down there as well and thanks everyone
for tuning in we love you very much and
we'll see you soon peace
bye atlas
really blessed by our relationship
um and thanks for your inspiration on uh
shifting me more towards the math and
the logic side of things i think that's
really important and also um thanks for
shifting me
even towards the rock and being even
more aware of the rock i think that was
another important i've been becoming
very aware of that rock lately over the
last couple of years with this mask and
vaccine nonsense yes actually
investigating what is in the vaccines
this is a bad situation
they're not real vaccines this is not a
real crisis the lockdowns are all fake
they're designed to destroy the economy
these people are trying to shut down the
mass awakening that you want and that i
want before it even happens
and this bit with apple cancelling the
last video actually blocking it from all
apple mobile devices that's just a taste
of what's to come
so understand they're enemies of the
mass awakening
they don't want it to happen they want
human humanity to stay in the dark so
that they can continue to run things
their own
and that's what i've been becoming aware
of and that's why
i seem aggressive about it i feel
aggressive
i love you and i love that vibration
actually it's really insightful and
important for us moving forward to
actually succeed with this planetary
awakening it's perfect thank you
excellent so i i really feel like in a
sense like a younger
um
like a younger in a sense version of you
that's i'm really excited about it from
a scientific math perspective but also
from a like a spiritual consciousness
artistic perspective um and it's really
beautiful
well i hope it's a lot easier for you
than it was for me
and hopefully for the next generation
right for the little 15 year olds right
now that are excited about it you know
you